Bitton Stein's innovation factory has an
impressive exterior design and
impressive experiments inside the staff
have no fixed workplace instead they
push their equipment and materials
through the new open plan office and
take desks that are not in use at the
moment the new system is only a few
weeks old sales development logistics
and production all work closely together
the aim is faster product development
basically this system eliminates
downtime all the time spent finding
agreement with colleagues phoning
everybody to shut your meetings it's all
superfluous
we don't need special appointments to
interact because everyone sits together
anyway and can collaborate on their
projects directly
Fintan Stein CEO dieter spot oriented
the whole new building toward better
communication short paths were crucial
it's less than 30 steps from production
to development other departments are
just a little further
does this really foster communication
and exchange - no sir
there's cross-fertilization through
feedback from customers ideas from
research and development and productions
but to implement such a system you need
a different working world a
communicative working world the whole
building is set up for encounters seeing
your colleagues having an overview of
everything and coming together in common
house Connect intensified contact aims
to produce competitive advantages the
mid-sized company wants to stand out
from the competition through innovations
that means the staff has to develop new
electric drive systems for industrial
robots faster than before couldn't a
Viking among customers expect ever
shorter development phases we used to
have a year to bring a new product onto
the market and serve our customers it's
now they have much higher expectations
more like half a year we have to deliver
the same or even a better result in half
the time that's the pressure we feel
45 46 47 steps and the sales manager is
face to face with his colleague in
production vinton stein invested
thirty-five million euros in this new
factory and staff are speaking more
frequently and intensively with each
other than in the company's other plans
but does everyone like the changes
people differ some are open to new
things and of course they get with the
program immediately they see the
advantages and then there are people who
want to preserve what they have they
want to work the same way they did
before but the arguments we have faster
delivery times to the customers and
greater efficiency get them on board -
part of the new concept is better
working conditions production here is
astonishingly quiet the forklift is the
loudest machine here so the overall
atmosphere is more like an office than a
factory our most important goal was to
give production workers the same
conditions as the people in
administration a clean working
environment low noise levels no
unpleasant smells that means wherever
needed we've installed exhaust
ventilators all our production machines
are sound insulated to keep the noise
level in production extremely low the
innovation factory develops new models
faster it used to take an average of 8
months now the company estimates it
takes seven the new concept seems to be
working